وتيره التحول التدريجي من الوقود الاحفوري
الى المصادر البديله تعززت مع تنام
المخاوف المتعلقه بامن الطاقه وتقلبات
الاسعار جراء الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
فكيف تبدو افاق التحول نحو الطاقه
المتجدده في بلادنا العربيه وهل تنجح بعض
الدول العربيه الى التقليل من اعتمادها
على مصادر الطاقه الاحفوريه
بل اذا انتقلنا الى مرحله التصنيع نجد انه
راح تخلق وظائف باعداد كبيره صراحه
والتكنولوجيا يمكن نقلها الى الدول
العربيه حتى نستطيع صناعه هذه التكنولوجيا
ويمكن هذه نقدر نقول فائده سادسه يمكن
نقدر نحطها امامنا فكيف تبدو جهود بعض
الدول العربيه للتحول نحو استخدام الطاقه
المتجدده احدث تحديات امام الطاقه
المتجدده هي الكلفه هناك بعض الدول التي
قد تكون امكانياتها الماديه اقل ولكن من
استطاع من خلال وضع التشريعات تسمح للقطاع
الخاص بالاستثمار في مواضيع الطاقه
المتجدده من المضي بشكل جيد صحيح احنا
متوسط او خلينا نحكي نسبه انتاج الطاقه
المتجدده في الدول العربيه لا تزال اقل من
المتوسط العالمي ولكننا ماشيين بوتيره
يعني خلال السنوات القادمه اتوقع ان نصل
الى المتوسط لعالمه ونتجاوزه فاحنا عندنا
طبعا في خط الاستراتيجيه في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه بانه حيكون الاعتماد على
الطاقه المتجد نسبه 50% في حلول عام 2030
لماذا كل هذا الحديث في العالم هذه
السنوات على الطاقه المتجدده وضروره
الذهاب اليها كتالات اسباب رئيسيه السبب
الرئيسي الاولاني هو موضوع سمعنا كثيرا في
موضوع التغيرات المناخيه الاحتباس الحراري
قمم الارض وقمم المناخ التي حصلت اذا بقي
العالم على استخدام الطاقه الاحفوريه في
نفس الوتيره اللي بيستخدمها حاليا متوقع
ان فعلا ترتفع درجه الحراره لاكثر من
درجتين السبب الثاني اللي هو سبب اقتصادي
احنا لاحظنا بالسنوات العشره الاخيره خاصه
انخفاض اسعار الطاقه المتجدده وخاصه بعد
دخول دوله مثل الصين على خط تصنيع الخلايا
الشمسيه والسبب الثالث اللي هو السبب اللي
هو امن التزود بالطاقه انا عندما تكون
مصادر الطاقه محليه لا يستطيع اي جهه ان
تمنع الشمس او الرياح من الدخول الى هذه
الدوله
دول التي لا تنتج الطاقه الاحفوريه
وتستورد اكثر هي مطالبه طبعا بان تنوع
مصادر يعني الطاقه اولا لتحقيق ما يصطلح
عليه بالامن الطاقي والسياده الطاقيه ولكن
ايضا من تخفيض هذه الفاتوره الطاقيه
وتخفيض ايضا من الاستيراد المغرب سار في
هذا الاتجاه ودول اخرى سارت في هذا
الاتجاه ربما نحن الان ندخل في مرحله
جديده يعني المرحله الاولى دعني اقول هي
مرحله انطلاق يعني هذه
الاستراتيجيه هذه المرحله الان هي مرحله
ضبط يعني تنزيل هذه الاستراتيجيه اولا من
خلال الانتقال من استعمال الطاقه فقط في
انتاج الكهرباء الى استعمال الطاقات
المتجدده في قطاعات اخرى ان الدول العربيه
بامكانها نظرا لكثره المعادن المتوفره
عندها ان تجلب ما يسمى بالصناعه الطاقيه
لا نكتفي باستهلاك المعدات واستيرادها بل
ننتقل الى مرحله متقدمه
الوطن العربي كله يقع ضمن منطقه الحزام
الشمسي الحزام الشمسي التي هي تتمتع باعلى
اشعاع شمسي على مستوى العالم يعني كانت
الشركات الاوروبيه جميعها تريد ان تستثمر
بانتاج الطاقه الكهربائيه من خلال الطاقه
الشمسيه في شمال افريقيا والشرق الاوسط
وتصدير الطاقه الكهربائيه لاوروبا
[موسيقى]
المواطن العادي يعني كل ما لديه من احتمال
ان تصل الكهرباء له بشكل موثوق وبشكل
وبجوده عاليه سواء اتت من طاقه متجدده او
اتت من طاقه حوريه التوعيه قد تكون يمكن
في منظور اخر ليس من الطاقه المتجدده
تحديدا وانما في كفاءه الطاقه استهلاك
الوقود
الطاقات المتجدده ليس قرار تقني الطاقات
مجدده المتجدده هي استراتيجيه كامله
الاركان والقرار السياسي يترجم طبعا على
مستوى المؤسسات فهناك الحكومه التي تضع
الاطار وتضع التشريعات وتضع استراتيجيات
ولكن هناك المؤسسات المكلفه ثم ايضا هناك
مؤسسه اخرى تعنى بالبحث العلمي تعنى
بمجلات اخرى فاذا هناك نوع من البناء
المؤسساتي الذي فعلا هو مدعوم ايضا
بتشريعات يقع تحينها باستمرار
انا اتوقع انه فعلا انه موضوع اشراك
القطاع الخاص اشي مهم جدا لانه المال بيد
القطاع الخاص وهم من يستطيع ان يستثمر
ولكن يجب ان تكون هناك قوانين يعني واضحه
قوانين بصراحه تساعد الاستثمار وتحفظ حق
برضو الحق العام في هذا الموضوع اذا اردنا
احنا فعلا نشر الطاقه المتجدد اكثر فيجب
ان يتخلى عن موضوع حقوق الملكيه الفكريه
وانما ان يتم ان فعلا السماح للدول
الناميه للدول الاخرى ان تقوم بنقل هذه
التكنولوجيا هل يمكن ان يكون فعلا هذا
نموذج ملهم سواء للمملكه او لبقيه الدول
هو فعلا نموذج رائع جدا من حيث عمليه
توليد الكهرباء ومن حيث عمليه استهلاك
الكهرباء فنعم في اذا كان الاستهلاك يعني
بطريقه ذات كفاءه عاليه فيكون انتاج سهل
على هذه المصادر التي تعتمد على الطاقه
المتجدده وعلى عمليه تخزينها اليوم هو
عباره عن نظام متكامل يعتمد على ليس فقط
توليد الطاقه من الطاقه المتجدده وهي
عباره عن 100% وانما ايضا على استبدال
الطاقه من مصادرها الرئيسيه
[موسيقى]
اولا اهم شيء قضيه الحوكمه التي اشرتم
اليها في السابق واعتقد ان هذه لابد ان
تعى احظى بعنايه خاصه الامر الثاني انا
اعتقد اهم شيء يجب ان تنتبه الى الدول
العربيه في اطار الشراكه بين القطاع العام
والقطاع الخاص هي ان تقرا العقود بان هذه
العقود هي عقود معقده لذلك نحن نحتاج الى
خبره قانونيه عاليه جدا لكي تكون هذه
العقود في صالح دولنا الامر الثالث وهو قد
نجد نوع من التلكؤ لدى بعض القطاعات في
الالتزام بالتطبيق او باستعمال الطاقات
المتجدده اخر نقطه يمكن ان نتحدث عنها وقد
لا ينتبه لها الكثيرون وهو الجانب البيئي
صحيح ان الطاقات المتجدده تعالج القضايا
البيئيه يعني سواء داخل المدن او خارج
المدن ولكن انا اعتقد انه حتى الطاقه
المتجدده في حد ذاتها هي ايضا فيها
اشكالات يجب ان يفكر فيها في المستقبل
لا اريد ان اسميها عيوبا ولكن فعلا هناك
بعض المحاذير وبعض القضايا يجب التعامل
معها من البدايه على سبيل المثال الطاقه
الشمسيه الالواح الشمسيه لها فتره 25 سنه
بعد 25 سنه انت يعني اين ستذهب بهذه
الالوان موضوع الصيانه موضوع انه تاهيل
مهندسين وفنيين انهم يستطيع ان يتعاملوا
مع المشاكل التي تطرا من مواضيع الطاقه
المتجدده في اعاده التدوير يجب علينا
التفكير جليا وخاصه معظم الدول العربيه
لديها مشاريع ضخمه حاليا من الطاقه
الشمسيه هي بحاجه فعلا انه يتم انشاء هاي
المصانع لاجل التدمير للمحافظه على البيئه
فهي يعني في بعض المحاذير الاخرى يعني
احنا بالنسبه للطاقه المتجدده اللي هي ان
احيانا بحاجه الى مساحات واسعه والحمد لله
احنا في الوطن العربي يعني لدينا مساحات
واسعه ممكن انه يتم الاستفاده منها انه
الموضوع اللي هي انا ذكرته موضوع اللي هي
عمليه انه احنا بحاجه انه الى التخزين هل
انا استخدم بط اريات هل استخدم طاقه مائيه